Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
The Spider-Man Across the Spider-Verse
people just revealed a new deleted scene
with Tom Holland's MCU, Spider-Man.
So we'll break it all down.
There were a lot of really cool ideas
and deleted scenes
that didn't make the final cut.
So I'll focus more on that.
Tom Holland,
Tobey Maguire, Andrew Garfield stuff
and what their plans are for those
characters in Beyond the Spider-Verse
because they do plan to crossover
with those live action characters more.
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos.
There's a bunch of multiverse
related stuff
like spider-verse related stuff
happening through Loki Season 2 episodes
that'll all culminate in Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty in Secret Wars.
There's a lot of crossover they'll
building up to in the Spider-Verse movies,
I do think everything they're doing
in Spider-Man across the Spider-Verse
Spider-Man beyond the Spider-Verse
will culminate in secret wars
with the MCU when they get to that movie
So do not be surprised when we see some of
these characters show up in live action.
But this new Tom Holland deleted scene
was revealed in their art book
they just released because the movie's
animated, most of their deleted scenes
either got cut in the animatics stage
like they didn't fully color them,
or they started life as a cool idea
or a test for something bigger.
Later on.
But Because the movie
took so long to make.
It took about four years.
That's why you might have watched
a different version
of the movie in theaters,
depending on where you live in theaters.
there was a bunch of talk on Twitter
or social media platforms about people
seeing different cuts
of the movie, different scenes, depending
on which theater they saw the movie in.
that's because they were still
working on the movie right up to the North
American release, which happened
after some of the international releases.
in the new Tom Holland MCU Spider-Man
cameos scene, the most notable thing is
that he's wearing his far from home suit
and he's super tiny compared to the other
adult versions of Spider-Man.
Being a high schooler like Miles Morales.
They'll grow into their roles
literally and figuratively.
the reason why
I think he's wearing his far from home
suit is because the movie took so long
to make like four plus years
when they were actually making the scene,
figuring out Tom Holland's cameos
and what it was going to be.
It was long before Spider-Man
Far from home, came out.
They didn't want to spoil his final suit
from that movie.
but it does confirm
that he was recruited
for the Spider Society by Spider-Man 2099.
But the secret with that was pretty much
that any version of Spider-Man
from the multiverse,
any universe, was offered membership
except for Miles Morales.
they went for no homers joke
from The Simpsons Stonecutters episode,
like a special club
that everybody wanted to be part of.
That only one version of Spider-Man
was not allowed to join.
I now call to order the first meeting
of the ancient mystic society of
no homers. Yes,
Phyllis.
Can I join?
No homers.
the whole reasoning behind that, though,
is that he was meant to be the original
anomaly to what they're calling the canon
in the web of life and destiny.
Like everything that is supposed to happen
according to the sacred timeline
which is the big Loki Easter egg too,
because a lot of what they were doing
was basically what they did during Loki,
just calling them different things.
the spider society was acting a lot
like the TVA,
protecting the sacred timeline, except
with a bunch of versions of Spider-Man.
I'm not really expecting to see
a bunch of Spider-Man related characters
in Loki Season two,
but there might be a couple of references
to this the whole idea in the movie.
Is that the spider that bit Miles
was originally from Earth.
42 miles is Earth
and brought to the alternate universe
by the spot during their initial tests of
the collider.
it looks like what's going on in
this scene is it's
when Miles has just been brought
to the Spider society by Spider Gwen
in Jessica Drew, and he's being taken
to talk to Spider-Man 29 nine.
in there in the middle
of giving him the tour.
And he just gawking at everyone like,
Oh, my God, look at this is so crazy.
it seems like MCU, Tom Holland's
Spider-Man is talking to another version
of Jessica
Drew Spider Woman just based on the way
her costume, her hair sticks out there.
I know there were a billion questions
about this.
There are infinite versions of Spider-Man.
Look like a billion different Spider-Man
in this movie.
the directors and the artists.
In a lot of case,
that most of these variants
are not specific named comic book versions
only a few of them are like
most of them are just alternate versions
of Peter Parker.
Spider-Man
from the main comic book universe.
There are a ton of versions
of Jessica Drew's Spider Woman,
but most of them are not from the comics.
I think they're meant to be over
70, though, that were named ones specific
to the comics like bombastic Batman manga
verse, Spider-Man, Ultimate Spider-Man.
From that cartoon series,
you get the idea.
This one over here on the left
side is an example of a comic book
accurate version of Iron Spider.
Peter Parker.
They actually had a version of that
during Spider-Man Far from home.
They were going to do comic book
accurate Iron Spider during that movie.
Completely separate thing, though.
this would have been
what his new upgraded suit
looked like when the former iron spider
suit, combined with his advanced suit
to make that gold looking symbol.
They usually have a bunch of different
versions of this kind of thing.
When they do the live
action, Spider-Man movies, too,
Like many, many different ideas
about what
the new suits are going to look like this
iron spider looks like he's talking
to another Jessica Drew
variant wearing a suit that's based more
on the classic Spider-Man 616 version.
There's a Spider-Man 2099 variant
of Spider Rex that looks a little bit
more like a Velociraptor Spider
Rex in the comics is an actual T-Rex.
the other super weird
version of Spider-Man here,
like there are a billion in this scene,
but the weird version, like zooming in.
Hans There is the balloon
looking Spider-Man with the two eyes
like he's a version of Spider-Man
who's a floating orb of some kind
Let me know if you think this is
a specific reference
to any comic book moments
or if he's just one of their
original creations
for the movie, like create the weirdest
looking Spider-Man versions
that you possibly think of.
There are a ton of other iron
spiders in 616.
Peter Parker Spider-Man
variants in the background here too.
way over on the left.
You see, Webslinger
and Widow are versions of them.
They were a little bit different
in the actual movie.
the main reason why I think
this got deleted, like why they didn't
have this big Tom Horn cameo seen here
is because they weren't ready to have MCU.
Tom Holland's Spider-Man
meet a version of Miles Morales.
Like they actually want to do that
at some point in the future,
but they didn't want to figure it out now.
So it's one of those situations where
like everybody at the table has to agree,
like Sony can't do anything that they want
with the Spider-Man character.
I think their contract with Marvel about
the way they use Peter Parker Spider-Man.
Tom Holland's character is very specific
about what each company
can do on their own, so it's just easier
to completely get rid of the scene.
They did reference him, though,
with that doctor Strange Earth 19999 joke
everyone
to know that I was Spider-Man before.
You still know
Did it work?
that was meant to be a reference to their
two spells during Spider-Man No Way Home.
one of the other big reasons
why you didn't see larger cameos, things
like physically larger
cameo scenes from Tom Holland, Spider-Man,
Andrew Garfield or Tobey Maguire is
because most of the movie was Spider-Man
2099, the Spider force
going after Miles Morales,
trying to trap him because they didn't
want him to save his father.
end, I think most people will agree
that Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man,
Andrew Garfield, Tom Holland, Spider-Man
would not be on board with that plan.
just easier to show them
in, not have cameo scenes
and then do bigger cameo scenes with them
during Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse
Lord and Miller also said that they tried
longer live action scenes like different
live action scenes,
but it got a little too silly,
so they pulled way back on that.
So the play trying to find a better way
to do that,
by the time
they get to beyond the Spider-Verse,
well when we're talking about
Tom Holland's
MCU Spider-Man
crossing over with Miles Morales
for the first time,
like them actually meeting each other,
there is a canonical version of Miles
Morales inside the MCU movies.
There was a Spider-Man
homecoming deleted scene where the Prowler
Donald Glover, who also has a very big
cameo in the movie in his Prowler costume.
this was meant to be MCU Prowler
in this scene
during homecoming
he calls his nephew Miles Morales
that scene was
meant to take place before the events
of Avengers Infinity War in the snap.
So at the time a lot of people assume
that they just use the five year time
jump and say, Miles
Morales did not get snapped in.
That's how they explain him being so much
older and closer to Tom Holland's age
when they show him in live action.
Tom Holland
even talked about them doing crossovers
with Miles Morales
in his Spider-Man movies Kevin Feige
has been a little cagey
about live action.
Miles Morales In the MCU movies recently,
but they kind of answered that question
right after Spider-Man
Across the Spider-Verse came out
and Amy Pascal revealed
that Sony had been working on
an actual Live-Action Miles Morales movie,
but it wouldn't be released until
after Spider-Man beyond the Spider-Verse.
so a lot of you see the way
these plans are kind of playing out
in Sony's mind in Marvel's
mind behind the scenes, like, Oh,
okay, starting to make a little more sense
now, the way they're doing this,
because there was so much live action
crossover in across the spider-verse.
They'll be more
and beyond the spider-verse
the theory right now is that you're
setting up the spider-verse characters
to cross over into the MCU live action
universe Four Secret Wars.
would it not be cool
to see those characters
in live action and for them to substitute
the spider force for the Thor core,
they would be such a bigger payoff.
But it involved a lot of dollars
changing hands between Sony and Marvel.
But Sony would definitely want
that Avengers money
then at some point after Secret Wars,
they can do that live action.
Miles Morales movie
because Lord and Miller
also said that there would be
more Spider-Verse movies,
but they would not follow Miles Morales
any more like his story
within the Spider-Verse movies
would end with Beyond the Spider-Verse
because they're going to be covering
the future of his story in the live
action movies
Shameik Moore is the voice of Miles
Morales in those Spider-Verse movies,
people got a little crazy when he said
he wanted to be the live action
version of the character.
I think mostly because he's a little old
and they want to do a younger version
of the character.
so that he seems younger than Tom
Holland's MCU.
Spider-Man but pretty solid
bet that we'll see that live
action Miles Morales movie
right after secret wars
maybe if we're lucky,
we'll get some Easter eggs
during Spider-Man
four or Spider-Man five.
But there's no way they're going to do Tom
Holland's Spider-Man five before
Secret Wars Let me know in the comments.
Where do you want to see
Miles Morales show up in live action
First
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up
next week.
My Ahsoka Episode 4 video will post
after they release it.
Click here for that Spider-Man
Beyond the Spider-Verse teaser trailer
video and click here for my Ahsoka
Episode 4 Trailer Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!